وان لم يكن رسميا بعد لكن معركه زعامه
الحزب الجمهوري قد بدات قبل موعدها الفعلي
بخمسه اشهر
الخصماني معروفان دونالد ترامب الرئيس
السابق للولايات المتحده
ورونديس حاكم فلوريدا
جمعتهما سنوات من المصالح المتبادله
ووجهات النظر في ملفات الهجره والحدود
والدعم لاوكرانيا وفرقتهما طموحات السلطه
والحكم
صعود نجم ديسانتس في اعقاب انتخابات
التجديد النصفي نوفمبر الماضي لم يكن افضل
ما حصل لدونالد ترامب فبعد ان كانت ترامب
الداعمه الاول لديسانتس كمرشح لحاكم
الولايه انقلب الاخير عليه وقرر الخروج من
عباءته
قد لا يكون الامر مستحيلا لكنه يتطلب
الشجاعه ليصبح المرء حرا كما يقول ديسانتس
في كتابه
الاستطلاعات الاوليه تقول ان دي سانتس
يعاني امام ترامب فنحو 56% من الناخبين
الجمهوريين يؤيدون ترشح ترامب مقابل 20%
فقط يؤيدون ترشح
الطريق لاقتناس ورقه ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري
يمر عبر ولايات التصويت المبكر وخاصه من
ولايه ايوا ديسانتس سيسعى للفوز في هذه
الولايه لاعطاء زخم لحملته في بدايتها كيف
ربما باستخدام خطابات تبرز انجازاته
السياسيه في فلوريدا او بتقويه العلاقات
الشخصيه مع مرشحين جمهوريين اخرين بحيث
يحصل على دعمهم السياسي عند انسحابهم من
السباق
كرم حناوي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات